Wow hi I'm Melissa I'm French hi I'm
Anthony and I'm American
hi my name is Elia and I'm French I'm
Becky and I'm American I love all
cheeses I've never found a cheese I
don't love I have had American cheese's
but I'm not a huge fan Ria's friend yes
see all these cheese I know for sure
it's very mellow it's delicious but it's
good yeah I expect something very
smelling really pungent yeah I stand by
the line the stinky or the cheese the
better yes okay good then you'll love
her best day ever
um I expect to eat something that
doesn't taste like anything
chemicals yeah exactly
let's bring on the cheese's we're
starting with brie yes excellent what a
way to start it's a little more mellow
than other cheese's like camembert but
it's good its creamy it does the job and
it's delicious so for the American side
we have a nice baby Swiss you can tell
by the holes that it's the Swiss I
assume it's a baby Swiss cuz it's less
mature than an adult Swiss sargon baby
Swiss first right
yeah with a cracker I believe okay
that's how you eat it right we have to
use a cracker yeah that is like such an
American thing all right ready Cheers
hmm this is very American I feel like I
should have like a small glass of cheap
wine cheap wine yeah this is actually
good I mean mm-hmm
it does taste like cheese you're not a
lot of flavor in it doesn't taste like
anything it needs mustard Swiss cheese
always goes better with mustard now
let's do some real cheese yes that's
fair Cheers
that's more like it
so creamy yeah it's pretty good it is
very mild yes now that you say that like
yeah but it's very creamy and like it
coats your mouth prepared on this is the
baby though it's I think that they do
different things yeah like I wouldn't
put the Swiss and the brie on the same
sandwich like I woke them on different
and I would also be more likely to eat
the Brie just like this I think I like
the Brie better yeah personally oh yeah
it's got more flavor to it one more
character yeah really yeah no I agree
brie no one told me there'd be choices
if I had to pick I think I want to go
Swiss because I would like it on a
really good grilled cheese
this is a plus this is kind of it really
melts in your mouth
it looks like a brain so I'm not kidding
when I say the smellier the better
really so I think maybe we should start
with the American one because after this
one you're not gonna do that when you do
it'll probably blow her out of the water
shirt for the American we have a Colby
which is a bit of a stronger flavor most
often it's paired with like a Jack
cheese or something but not always on
its own but I like it it's delicious
Colby's always been good you know it's
like a safe cheese it is it's like it's
like a kid's cheese yes it's just kind
of like a right down the road cheese I
agree yeah I don't see a lot of
difference with the previous one I agree
see that's the problem with American
cheese is that to me they all kind of
taste the same this is something you
would serve to a kid like your doctor
school snack cheese that's good smell it
first okay so that's something oh it
smells delicious it's drunk
it smells almost like nutty or toasted
yeah why
[Music]
yes that's got some character to it
mm-hmm mm-hmm
super good movie mm-hmm it's very
pungent but like in a taste way I don't
know how to it's like not tart but it's
got a little bit of sourness I don't
know what I'm looking for here but it's
I see what you mean yeah you can taste
the funk in that burns yeah it's got
it's got a good amount of funk that's
good though it's super creamy it doesn't
like the smell right now can be
repulsive to certain people but when you
eat it it's actually delicious
if I had to pick I would probably pick
the French one in this case me too 100%
French one my breath is already oh yeah
for me would really depend on the
situation like this is more something
that I would with a meal versus at a
party and again if I'm in a party I
would go for the whole game probably I
know that's a great way to put it this
is more of like a nibbling cheese yeah
exactly and this is sort of like you
build something around this yeah really
like you have to imagine it with like
grapes and things like that around it
and it no llores it delicious yeah well
that's an interesting looking cheese I
have okay yeah this is very creative
it's just regular old cheddar this is
Wisconsin cheddar okay it's just wrapped
in a delightful black oh yeah I've never
tried that this is the hook fall so al
Haq father is whoa chief it goes really
well with sweet stuff as well like honey
and
and things like that it's really
powerful so like to be complement with
something sweet I don't eat that much
blue cheese I'm knocking a lot I'll
leave that whole block in front of
everyone God and God is my witness I
will leave that in front of this camera
oh just smell it this is good it's
strong and it's just America that's more
my style I love it yeah this is really
good mhm
this is what you want in a mac and
cheese this is this is just American
cheese this is good and this is a good
in Wisconsin mm-hmm you know it's a
little aids it's almost a little funky
you know yeah this actually has
character this is why this is probably
the most popular please I'm just gonna
say that I don't know if it's true I
actually like this one a lot do you
think it tastes great just nom on this
all by itself I am so ready I love blue
cheese and this looks like the funkiest
blue cheese I've ever like I've ever pop
oh it's it's strong oh I may have eaten
a little too much oh that's got a tank
you know it's strong cheese when you can
like feel it here burning yeah I forgot
how powerful this one is actually still
appear my bow yeah it's really tart
that's very
it's almost sour it's really so much
better when it has something like in a
salad or something else to really
complement it it's not something that
you know you don't just take blocks of
this and really go at it
that's for sure I have to say even in
France like not everybody's a big fan
because it's so strong cheddar Paul I'm
still thinking about it funky too funky
for me it depends on what I'm doing if I
have to be around other people I'm going
the cheddar
you know if I'm just alone alone then
it's gonna be the play Lewis yes weird
words averse Poppins too fine to choose
I would pick the cheddar my first
American cheese you know what I kind of
like the cheddar - to be honest
surprised people are gonna hate me I'm
so sorry but I like the cheddar better
although this is really good - I'm not
saying it's not good in its own way yeah
[Music]
this is American cheese places cheese
this is cheese I mean look at the
presentation this is so American cheese
no that's not cheese I am NOT a fan I
have not been a fan for a very long time
oh Jesus unreal cheese no use real
cheese be all grown up you can just roll
it up and just kind of like nibble at it
you're probably gonna want it to crack
or two but this is going for like this
first oh my god Wow
so Oh tastes like plastic so my kid
palate look way different than my adult
palate it smells like nothing else
matters a Hello it tastes like nothing
it tastes like cream of nothing I used
to be like repulsed by these but that's
not so bad I don't think this is a fair
representation of American cheese I know
it's a cultural representation but I
don't think it's a fair one no let's
talk about real cheese yeah what is this
camembert
yeah I've heard of that from like
wallace and gromit I think oh really
yeah it's like a Bri it's a little
creamier and it's stickier
so I think you like this those are some
of my favorite adjectives if you like
the Bri and you'd like the okay it's can
you smell this smell whoa right oh yeah
it doesn't smell bad like the other one
I can't pronounce but yeah it's still
it's Carlotta
it's kind of appetizing yes smell oh
that is good really good yeah there's
just good on its own I think if you have
this ones yeah one of the best Oh
mild and then it like turns into
something else a little bit yeah there's
that sharp sort of almost bitter it is a
little yeah right but it's not
overpowering like the clothes honestly
make this quick and easy I pick the
French one yeah screech I kind of pick
this one over all the cheese's yeah I'm
picking though they come if you really
pick that one I would definitely pick
the Kim oh man I hope you two alright
I'm gonna go for the frying those French
cheeses was an amazing experience this
is the best day I've had in a long time
I think that the French really had their
cheese's down it's a lot more character
I like that it's creamy and that it's
stinky and that it has character and
funk it's very different from the
American palate though which you know
some of them can be kind of revolting in
a way but you have to like you can learn
to love them because they have a lot of
different flavors to them American
cheese is good - it's a little firmer
it's a little more mild but like going
hand in hand it's hard to be French
cheese
the French cheese is like really
cultural thing for us it's so magical
and important it's such a big part of
our culture I'd absolutely try French
cheese again it's it's got a lot of
character it's got a lot of taste to it
and flavor just like it's already tight
[Music]